so a lot of entertainers are very quiet
about their political views bob ritchie
kid rock is not
but what's interesting according to him
his views are not uncommon in the
entertainment industry they're just
suppressed
we asked him by the way since he's a
frequent golf partner of former
president trump how did you first meet
him and what do you think of him and
above all
what do you think
of tony fauci
here's more of our extended interview
with kid rock
where did you meet trump
let me trump oh god at the white house
sarah palin in the white house
sarah palin asked him to uh i was
friendly with her and
early right when he got elected he
invited her to dinner and said bring
some interesting people
so she said she called me and ted up ted
nugent and was like hell yeah
ended up there we ended up becoming
buddies and spent a lot of time in the
golf course now and
it's really weird get phone calls from
and stuff it's just kind of mind-blowing
what's he like to play golf with
awesome
so much fun really why
he just knows how to have fun doesn't
take it too seriously yeah you know he's
engaging
it's just you're just cutting it up just
open with politics and i was there with
him one day when he ended the caliphate
he wanted to put out a tweet and it was
like
i don't like to speak out of school i
hope i'm not but
something like he's like
tell him like yeah the tweet was and i'm
paraphrasing but it's like you know if
you ever join the caliphate you know and
try to do this you're going to be dead
he goes what do you think
awesome all right yeah tweet that out i
was like i can't add anything better
than that but then it comes out it's
very
it's reworded and more political and
like you know a little politically
correct and i'm like just being pretty
you know we're looking at maps
i'm like you know i'm like am i supposed
to be like you know
i make dirty records sometimes
i do it here you didn't think you'd have
a hand what do you think we should do
about north korea i'm like
what i don't think i'm qualified to
answer this
how does he how does he see you're still
playing golf with him down in florida
yeah yeah how's he seeing what's that
how's he seem
he seems great he seems great you know
after the election it was you know a
little you know a little different there
and
but
he's still the same guy
he sits down he just cuts it up
just starts cutting it up it's just how
sharp he is is incredible and you can
see now if you watch
a joe biden interview and you watch a
trump interview you're just like there's
there's no comparison yeah and trump
yeah he speaks off the cuff i understand
what it's like sometimes you get it
wrong yeah no this is that any other but
i would way rather hear somebody come
from here and get it wrong once in a
while
and see this contrived pretty much every
politician until he came along at some
level everything was scripted and i've
stood next to him in the white house and
right next to with the prepared notes
and watched him read like one sentence
then just one let's go
and you're like this is awesome kid rock
kid thank you great thing you like this
legislation or do you hate it i like it
you've been elected it's been fighting
for a long time that's why i liked him
from the beginning you know i i said you
know he was my guy before he even got
the nomination
a rolling stone and since that day till
now
bullets coming at you you know from
every angle
i mean if you had a manager
who was in control of your career he
would say you know maybe let's not weigh
in on this oh i've had managers that get
well manager punch you know i love
dearly he told me flat out when he
started to manage just so you know he
goes everything you've done to this
point in your career to get where i
would have told you no
well what does that tell you
i just gotta go with my heart
i just gone by my heart the seat of my
pants tried to be a good person you know
be educated if i'm gonna speak on some
things
sometimes not so much but whatever just
kind of call it like i see it
we we had dinner last night and you
rolled up in a rolls-royce the let's go
brandon edition yes
except for the waffle house plate with a
waffle house plate so for our viewers
who might want
the rolls-royce let's go branded edition
like where where can you get one
you go on this thing called google and
you type in you know car badges
let's go brandon and there's companies
that come up on my truck i got one says
white boy edition
there's all these crazy but it looks
official so you know i would never drive
a foreign car be driven i used to like
to say to myself like i'm so proud you
know for how hard i work and you know
what i charge people for shows is what i
think is fair because i can hold my head
high because i feel i've never made an
unhonest dollar off of working math back
and so i get for rolls-royce
i'm in nashville so i'm not in detroit
so it's thing but it came for sale this
thing and i had this waffle house
license plate holder forever and i'm
like
i need a car to put that thing on
i need to get that rolls royce and then
the let's go brandon badge came out i'm
like oh there is a heaven i'm like this
is just too good
this is too much fun you know what i
mean without naming their names are they
and you would know are there other
people in your business who agree with
you privately
yeah and it was funny during the last um
you know election when trump's thing is
i had some people on his inside say it
to me they were naming off hollywood
people
and they they kept going like you know
yeah they're in the closet and i'm like
those people are all gay
that's nuts and they're like no no no
they're closet trump fans i'm like oh
man
i was like that was kind of mind-blowing
you know like i'm not going to talk out
of school on these people they obviously
don't want to be out in the open yet for
for whatever reasons they have but yeah
there's there's a ton of them they have
no idea me and trump talk about that a
lot we're like you know they have no
idea how many of us there are
you know the vocal ones sure you know
they already see them but they have no
idea how many of us there are out there
that
not are either trump fans or just you
know more conservative yeah right and
conservative to me i don't know to you
has changed when i was younger the
conservative was like you know
sweaters and college shirts oh
i haven't updated my look since the 80s
okay i'm not i'm not quick but you know
it was like if i said the f word when i
was young i was running out of the house
you know because i was about to get
paddled yeah or something like this and
you know holidays it's like
conservatives are a little hipper you
know it's you know a little more out in
the open well they're the people i'm
sure that'll be the headline from our
you know the from the left wing i can
already see their headlines on this
interview it's like
tucker and kid rock's love story
together like
i'm not embarrassed i'm a fan no i mean
look i respect anyone who thinks for
himself
even if that person reaches different
conclusions for me what i don't respect
is people who just sign up for the
program because someone in power told
them to think it i don't respect that
why would you we can we can agree in
certain levels to think each other like
each one another is a dumbass that's
totally fine i'll have great
conversations i love it what what's your
view of fouchy
yeah
you speak for many when you say that did
did you believe him at the beginning
fatchy i believed all the bulls
beginning yeah i mean we were kind of
shooting this documentary and i'm like
so embarrassed i'm like in here like
everyone's spraying off ups packages and
like spraying on the doorknobs
and like a couple months of that like
what
it's like so this pretty much like is is
knocking out overweight on healthy
people
i'm like i'm good
and so most of my friends after people
start getting it and you're like you
know some people had a little worse
notice but it was nothing you know
you know and i don't want it you know
you know
throw any sign of people that had a bad
time or passed away with it it's it's
horrible when when anyone's lost um
but to me i was like this is some bull
and all this mass you know one day it's
just the disinformation that's in the
world now yeah at every level that's for
sure no what to believe
so there's a man who talks and lives
like you might talk or live if you were
totally insulated from big companies and
could afford it so it was a fascinating
experience spending a couple days with
kid rock on his property in tennessee
all for a documentary we're making for
the tucker cross original series coming
out this summer it's going to be good
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else